I don't know if you've noticed but gas
is expensive these days is there a
solution well for years politicians have
been telling us that ethanol is a
renewable energy source that will reduce
pollution and our reliance on foreign
oil I am for sugarcane biofuels
switchgrass and corn based ethanol
because of our need for in dependence on
foreign oil we will send our energy
dollars to the Midwest not the Middle
East but an increasing number of people
are skeptical about using ethanol for
fuel ethanol it's a dangerous idea it's
a waste of our resources and putting
money into something I do not think will
work corn based ethanol also known as
grain alcohol and moonshine is made by
fermenting and distilling corn you can
enjoy it as an alcoholic beverage or
burn it as fuel the u.s. currently
produces more than 7 billion gallons of
ethanol each year and most of us
routinely use gasoline that contains up
to 10 percent ethanol we talked to Ron
Valley the science correspondent for
Reason magazine to learn more about the
ethanol fuel craze the ethanol mandates
came about as an outgrowth of an effort
to lower air pollution from gasoline it
became part of the environmental
community response to global warming
fuelled by support from
environmentalists and the corn Lobby
politicians have showered the ethanol
industry with subsidies ethanol
subsidies right now the main one is what
they call the blenders credit is 51
cents per gallon the corn farmers also
get an additional subsidy for just
growing corn well the other thing is is
that we certainly wouldn't want cheap
ethanol being imported from somewhere
else undercutting our corn farmers so we
have in 54 cent per gallon tariffs
against ethanol imported from other
countries if you add up all the
subsidies that go to ethanol it's
probably in the area of about 8 bill
dollars some people like the folks at
the American Coalition for ethanol say
that the subsidies are justified and we
believe the benefits that ethanol
received from the federal government are
warranted because ethanol is a homegrown
fuel it creates jobs and and increases
economic development in rural areas it
reduces our dependence on foreign oil
and provides Americans with a clean fuel
choice to help clean up our environment
actually the question of whether or not
Evon all produces less pollution than
gasoline is a very open question if you
add up all the costs for example the
energy that goes into making fertilizer
if you add up the energy that goes into
plowing the field if you add up the
energy that is used to produce the
ethanol you add all that up it's if the
net energy balance is not very good in
fact a lot of researchers believe that
in fact you're putting more energy into
F producing a health than you get out of
it when you burn it okay but at the very
least ethanol reduces greenhouse gas
emissions right
recent research actually shows that what
has happened is is that as we are
turning more food into fuel in the
United States's the farmers around the
world in developing countries Brazil and
Indonesia specifically are now boosting
their food production but to do that
they're chopping down more of the
rainforests and plowing up more
grasslands to do that this releases a
lot more carbon dioxide than is being
saved by producing noble fuels in the
United States that's always much worse
for the environment than gasoline it
turns out it also turns out that
pollution may not be the biggest problem
associated with ethanol we're in the
midst of a world food crisis through
has not been this expensive for over
three decades and this is pushing
several million people to the edge of
starvation and part of the problem is
that we are turning food into fuel the
amount of grain that it takes a metal
corn that it takes to produce one tank
20 gallon tank of ethanol could feed one
person for an entire year
the IMF estimates that 60% of the recent
increase in prices of food around the
world is a result of our biofuels
subsidies and our biofuel craze if you
will in the United States and in Europe
as well and this has to stop
so ethanol is bad for taxpayers bad for
consumers bad for the environment and
bad for the world's poor
does anyone benefit from ethanol the
winners from ethanol subsidies are the
farmers and secondly of course the big
agribusiness companies places like
archer's Daniels Midland are making a
ton of money as well our County grows 14
million bushels of corn and just by the
narrowing of the basis are increasing
our prices that's an extra 3.5 million
dollars in the farmers pockets overall
ethanol production increases the farm
income in America 4.5 billion dollars
annually as you might imagine ethanol
subsidies are also very popular with
politicians from corn producing states I
strongly believe one solution to this
oil addiction is an increased use of
domestically produced biofuels such as
ethanol everything about our domestic
renewable fuels is good good good the
environmental communities finally
realize its error there against ethanol
subsidies at long last so why are the
Senators part of Congress peoples still
supporting this largely because this is
how they garner votes the farmers are a
very loud lobby here in Washington DC
and it would be very politically brave
to oppose them at this point in fact
despite all the criticism the US
government recently increased its
support of ethanol in December of this
past year Congress passed and the
President signed legislation that would
mandate the production of 36 billion
gallons of biofuels by 2022 now what
does that net out to in order to produce
that under current conditions that would
basically equal
turning the entire American corn crop
into ethanol should the government
increase its support of emerging
technologies like cellulosic ethanol now
a lot of people who are in favor biofuel
disabled yes you're right Ron we should
not be making corn ethanol - what we
really should be focusing on is well
cellulosic ethanol and what they mean by
that is to use if you will plant
material not grain and that it probably
is a little bit better but it still
doesn't get rid of the problem you have
to devote cropland to producing these
biofuels and that will mean again higher
food prices a viable renewable energy
source would be great for everyone
don't subsidies create an incentive for
biofuel researchers to innovate look oil
prices are the highest that they've ever
been
if renewable fuels biofuels were such a
good deal they would already be emerging
without government subsidies without
Dermott health these subsidies are
actually telling us is that they're not
a good deal that we should be devoting
our resources defining other alternative
sources of fuel rather than turning food
into fuel here's to an end to ethanol
subsidies for Reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie